hi my name is Chris Gagne and I'm an
agile coach today I'll talk about their
working agreement the working agreement
is a documented set of ground rules that
the team creates and follows in order to
improve their productivity and happiness
think of some of the things that slow
your team down for example some teams
find that their meetings are more
productive when everyone puts away their
phones and laptops unless they need them
for the meeting other teams find that
having individuals come too late to the
stand up limits or usefulness the best
way to create a working agreement is to
use a little bit of reverse psychology
get together as a team and brainstorm
all the ways your team can fail then
prioritize the five most significant
risks to your team based on their
likelihood of occurring and the severity
of their impact then come up with a
specific rule that would prevent that
from happening so for instance perhaps
the team agrees that having people
working in a laptop during meetings is a
big risk to their productivity they then
create a rule that says the only person
who should have their laptop open is the
person presenting their screen to the
rest of the team all their electronics
should be put away that there's a
production issue the person working on
the issue should leave the room so it's
not to distract everyone else see if you
can come up with about five to seven
rules to help with the top five risks
you've identified then post this in a
conspicuous location if you're
co-located write each role in a sticky
note and paste it on the wall near your
desk if you're distributed create a page
in your wiki or a similar space the
whole team is responsible holding each
other accountable into following the
working agreement be polite and ask each
other to follow the rules that you agree
to escalate only as a last resort
review your working agreement regularly
at least once every sprint at the
retrospective the team can add or remove
items to the working agreement at any
time so long those general consensus if
your team creates and uses a working
agreement diligently you will soon find
that your team is happier and more
productive best of luck